before my father died I had a baby with
him and we're going to it will be raised
in captivity
it'll be raised privately to be the
greatest politician that has ever lived
my name is Megan McCain and I'm on a
news show called the view and Donald
Trump that [ __ ] riverboat casino
captain is talking [ __ ] about my father
again
my father was tortured for a hundred
years for this [ __ ] country and he
came back and he started seven wars
because he's a gentleman
[ __ ] you Trump I'm gonna wear my
father's skin mask and I'm gonna primary
Trump from the right come on the view
[ __ ] if you're that tough come on the
view you want another side to get a car
club dance you want this [ __ ] you want a
funky pitch Trump you wanna [ __ ] these
tents no you don't you wanna suck [ __ ]
but I won't [ __ ] you because the only
person I'll [ __ ] is dirty
a [ __ ] clubs I'll [ __ ] daddy's corpse